you know are you still single no I have
a girlfriend now yeah I need a girl for
a while now
really yeah it's fairly recent but you
know I had a girlfriend for a while then
we broke up I remember because when you
we're on the road together yet a girl
yeah and then I didn't after that yeah
yeah that's how it works I was like all
right that checks out descriptive it's
good guy Friday so let me know about hey
Suzanne got Fridays he likes the thicker
girls oh yeah curvy girls all days I
remember he was mad my homie was mad his
girl got a gym membership no yeah no
good all skinny I said this to Brendan I
said Brendan my homie asked me he's like
what kind of guy are you right he's are
you a ass man or your tip man what kind
of guy are you I'm like if I'm being
honest man yeah I'm like I'm a slow
metabolism kind of guy like the slower
the better man and I'm being so real you
will never find a real estate 'men like
slow habilis slow metabolisms you like
how you like my friend is like my friend
we were looking at two girls he goes tan
look at her and I go I know the [ __ ] and
he goes on he goes in that skirt and I
go otherwise jeez dude I go you like
they didn't like think he didn't like
thinking curvy girls he like fat girls
he liked big girl you know we call them
curving fat those son oh no no well how
big how big are the curves you know
sometimes you like T th IC ke thick yeah
I like thi cc no no so so that but
they're the god bless men like you
god bless women like that god bless the
difference I mean because we all need
love is ID he's getting filled with
right now his feet are movies like god
bless
afraid of it I'm not afraid I'm not
afraid of curves and I'm not afraid of
thick and I'm not going to just lighting
the ass for it I but I I am I step up to
the plate yeah and and you guys know if
you like I like girls with muscles huge
dicks I don't care beards it doesn't
matter as long as as long as you
handsome women they make fun of me
because I like a strong athletic woman
but I see big legs and a big booty then
then gets me yeah there's just something
really cool about it and I was talking
to was I talking to and started laughing
it and I found something out about
myself right so when I found out what
Santino
we were talking about cartoons and you
know growing up or whatever right and
there was a cartoon called eek the cat
do you guys remember this I'd have to
see it bring the can so it's a purple
cat and it was described like the cat
was a underdog you know it's a purple
cat with an underdog but his girlfriend
he's whoa a man uh hold on look yep that
pink one his girlfriend was this tall
big super curvy cat and they you know
they'd bring up the fact that that she
was big and he's like you think so quite
was like full gentleman is that where
you're at so yes I think I have
resonated with this cartoon so much
because it was an underdog that's it -
episode 7 Watchers listen Oh subway keep
saying curvy and it's triggered me cuz
that's there's a Derek screen curvy okay
let's break it down here would give us
an example an actress who you think is
like what what is what the is though
curvy look they're all curvy to me so
you had no problem Liz oh this is great
pull up Liz oh please hurry gee she is
pretty that's what I'm talking about
right there you got you're not a friend
in the house my leg
you're not afraid of that I think she's
stunning bro god I love you god bless
love you not being real glasses are
those I'm the old guy and I listened to
some of her songs she's talented as [ __ ]
no hey no one's not saying she gets sad
the songbird of her generation I love
that there are men like Zeus who are not
afraid of that and who find out there's
a ton of men who aren't afraid of that
no I'm not afraid of it but I'm gonna
call her thick hilarious who's like a
stunning just all-around great girl - is
Ashley Graham I think she's great ass
Ashley Graham she saw no super print huh
oh she's friend nxe as hell she's yeah I
think she's right she just migrated on
the Left see I would say she's more
that's delicious
yeah she's delicious yeah yeah yeah it's
so if you go on my Instagram I follow
three things I follow MMA all things MMA
oh wow artists love it and only
plus-size mom oh damn yeah yeah go to
his Instagram right now because I love
it I say if you're not into a bike we
can pull it up right now on my thing are
you're just gonna see curvy women good
for you yeah if you don't like dudes
bikes and [ __ ] dicks then go - oh
you're following yeah yeah just gonna
follow just oh they're gonna come yeah
yeah first one see let's let's get into
it
she's been oh girl scroll it good are
you gonna do she's such a [ __ ] come on
man she's curvy done Wow she's super bad
but I think so so there's a like there's
a second side to this I think it's also
cool because it's like you know a woman
like that can show a young girl that
there's not just one body time whatever
you are you can embrace that and I think
that's cool and you'll find love and
you'll find a man and you also find
diabetes now now we shouldn't either
honest well sometimes that's not the
healthiest she looks pretty healthy no
she
so my capital of baby yeah but lizard
their cholesterol it could be a little
high that one
the last picture she's look at that
right here yes that right there you see
that yeah I'm all with it dug curve
curve curve curve sir not in a moment
right now no not better in the moment no
she's bad she's hot almost all you you
have a little bit you need a little bit
but she tighten up that's on say are you
for you that's all and I appreciate you
playing ball right now but I have to
check you a little bit now you're right
cuz you know what intermittent fasting
wouldn't kill him and that's that's good
that's the thing now now I'm a fan of
that I know you are the biggest fan in
the pool I know and she's got a
beautiful thing her faces you know what
hazards cuz you know what I follow to is
a fashion over curve yeah they got all
the Plus Size Mars that let me see that
Oh fashion over Nova curb that's what
Nova has the baddest girl that mama
curve now we're talking it's fashion of
Alaska and of her that's not a
fashionable fashion she's hot as [ __ ]
I'll give you that
well I mean you know it is what it is
curvy girls man fashion of a curve is it
what to ends fashion no there we go yes
you know it is fashion no hmm yeah
alright huh
that's those alright I mean they don't
miss over here's what I'm saying man
looting album you can like everything's
a hit you can listen to it from start to
finish everything they pose hits you
just love that's how I am on the
CrossFit page grow with curls
bro ever come on guys that's just cool
you're all of your about that thing you
don't mind the Fupa the front yeah no
baby girl you like I like a curvy girl
yeah and baby girl
see that's not curvy this one ah oh now
she's hot huh
well no cuz producing be free so Brendan
like no no no she's perfect yeah yeah
she's pretty hot but
is your girl now hey soos RV's yeah
she's a curvier girl yeah white girl no
Latina oh hell yeah
Mexican actually you're an
equal-opportunity employer Equal
Opportunity but you know it's like hey
hey man is it's like I don't know that's
great see that census they don't miss
I'm telling you they got man they don't
miss you're right I want to go to
corporate take a tour of their of their
facility over there you should to be
just did you just to inspect things yeah
yeah Dora this mallanna calf right go
back up
see right here right there right where
your mouse is no that one she's she was
in a bunch of stuff and she's stunning -
beer majors that is their name oh really
yeah hey hey scroll down here - uh
beautiful girl what about now go the one
in the underwear in the rose that's sexy
to me actually I can IV I think you got
me of course I think it's hot bro oh yes
that's that's time that's light I'm too
light in the ass for that and that's but
I understand you know I 250 pounds I'm
too light in yes that's right but not
it's just not anxious because he's got
Holy Ghost power
well no yeah it's it's all about your
mindset and not damn it you can do it
it's all about your asset here's the one
thing about me I I tend to shy a little
bit away from when the weight is in the
abdominal region that's all that's just
me i-i'll get more down the trail that's
out stand it you that's outstanding
that's outstanding because you got a
waist you got that so so more of a shame
you guys think about like like butt
implants are you guys so not very nosy
lien but not butt implants but when they
take the fat from the stomach on a
Brazilian a lot I've seen it I might my
French girl had its outstanding Shore
and when you go to Miami
yeah all those women have done it and LA
I'm about here too I'm a fan oh you you
don't like fake asses and fake titties
no I'm a big fan of a woman yeah I mean
so yeah I like it all hunter what yeah
yeah no matter what but it's like I
think I want to date my sister you're
the kind of guy I'd want I would set my
girlfriend's up with yeah cuz most of my
friends can't do it
well you got a bill like that because
most my friends what a friend is like
like you try France bad guys yeah no hey
soos a good guy
where did you meet your current girl
that we met in DC DC improv yeah yeah
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]